>> Bret: DOUG McKELWAY LIFE
AND NATIONAL HARBOR MARYLAND.
NOT ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF DEMOCRATS
NOT ON THE SAME PAGE OF THE
POLITICAL PLAYBOOK.
THIS HAPPENED EARLIER THIS WEEK
IN WASHINGTON AND OF THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IS TRYING
TO TIGHTEN UP.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY PICKS
UP THAT STORY.
>> AND THE HOUSE CHAMBER
DEMOCRATS HAVE MORE SEATS, BUT
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE HEARING
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE, DEMOCRATS
LEFT A LOT OF EMPTY SEATS.
REPUBLICANS VOTED TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
>> THE MOTION PASSES.
>> BECAUSE ONLY TWO DEMOCRATS
SHOWED UP, THE PARTY WHOSE
PLATFORM INCLUDES A LINE THAT
READS, "CLIMATE CHANGE POSES A
REAL AND URGENT THREAT."
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A HEARING ABOUT
THAT THREAT.
>> WE HAVE UTRECHT.
IT IS A CHEAP TRICK.
WE WILL BE PREPARED.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY WAS
SHAKEN FURTHER WHEN REPUBLICANS
INSISTED A GUN BACKGROUND CHECK
BILL HE DID LANGUAGE ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS BUYING
GUNS.
TO NANCY PELOSI'S DISMAY,
REPUBLICANS SUCCEEDED IN
CONVINCING 26 DEMOCRATS TO JOIN
THEM IN AMENDING THE BILL BY
VOTING YES.
>> VOTE NO.
THE FACT IS A VOTE YES IS TO
GIVE LEVERAGE TO THE OTHER SIDE.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE THINKING OF
WAYS TO LIMIT USE OF THE TOOLS
THEY USED HERE CALLED A MOTION
TO RECOMMIT OR MTR.
>> CHANGES TO THE MTR WOULD BE A
NUCLEAR OPTION.
>> THEY WEAPONIZED THE MTR TO
FORCE VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS ONTO
THE RECORD ON HOT BUTTON ISSUES.
A SPOKESMAN FOR THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE CHIMED IN,
BUCKLE UP AND GRAB YOUR POPCORN
BECAUSE DEMOCRATIC BITING IS
ALREADY REACHING A BREAKING
POINT AND IT IS ONLY MONTH TWO
OF DEMOCRATS HOUSE MAJORITY.
JUST WAIT UNTIL THE PARTY
PRIMARIES BEGAN.
UNTIL THEN THE G.O.P. WILL NEED
TO RELY ON LOOPHOLES TO MAKE
THEIR MARK, THE NEXT THING THEY
TRIED COULD BE SQUASHED BY THE
SPEAKER.
>> HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
PASSING SOME HIGH-PROFILE AGENDA
ITEMS LIKE THE RESOLUTION
DISAPPROVING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATION AND A
PUBLIC PACKAGE.
DEMOCRATIC GROWING PAINS COULD
BE SHORT-LIVED, BUT THEN AGAIN